[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time
i'm rhett and i'm link this week at the
round
table of dim lighting we're going to
move
into a commune uh we both have our
laptops out i mean
nothing's about to get serious when
there's research happening we've got a
big decision to make because
we just have to decide which commune
we're going to move into there's lots of
them spread across
you want a pinky grand globe you want to
pinky swear right now yep that
we are we are going to join a column by
the end of this
thing it's the podcast here's the thing
we don't believe that pinky swears are
binding that's the sort of the cash 22.
don't get your hopes up um but i am
seriously considering it
so maybe there's a commune that's a an
anti-pinkish wear commune
and will fit right in people pinky
swearing at all times knowing that it's
always meaningless no a dinky square i
think he's quite i think he's swearing
that's like a really small square no
that's when you look at that dinky's
when you put your dinkies together did
you did you see what is a dinky uh i
mean i think it's another you're
motioning something as if
you're not making a winner as you're
saying you're calling a wiener a dinky
i've never had before i was just trying
to come up with a joke you saw a bad
trip
i saw the first half of it and then i
thought did you get to the to the dinky
part
oh yes um the finger trap
i mean it wasn't fingers that were in
there well i mean that what a
what a crazy movie yeah that's nuts man
dang
i don't know i've got it's my wreck
today that's not your right i reserved
the right to recommend the first half of
bad trip i don't know it's kind of you
know
you know if you doze off and then you
wake up and you're like i'm
maybe i can just keep watching this oh
yeah you can doze off and come back that
happened but
there's so many points in bad trip that
like
waking up and realizing what you're
watching is like
it's it was frightening like i was
i was shocked it's like that's not how a
man wants to wake up on the couch
yeah in a well you know a finger trap
with other things trapped in jessie and
i watched it together
and the thing that she was saying she
was like i don't know
if you can make this kind of movie
anymore like
seriously because well it just was made
taking it
i know i know that's the thing she was
like i don't know how i feel laughing at
it because
taking advantage of people and like the
idea of consent
is something that if you're making
really crazy prank videos
you're not getting any of that because
you want to get the authentic reactions
and i'm not
i'm not i'm not taking a stand on saying
that i think prank videos should be
outlawed and we don't know that they
didn't get post
scene consent i don't know but is that
consent
so yeah i don't know if we're
recommending it it frightened me when i
woke up
yeah yeah so we just watched it we're
not talking we're not recommending we're
just talking about it
you know i teased you this in the last
episode uh as
the as the world i mean
you know we're looking through this los
angeles
lens of return to normalcy from
um kovid and being
locked down quarantined safe and what
you know doing all these precautions but
some maybe we're a little behind maybe
you're in a spot where you're listening
and you're like well
things feel kind of already back to
normal for me i'm mouth-kissing
strangers already
i mean i don't know but at this point
right now i am very much
trying to figure out how i'm going to
reengage with my life as it was and a
lot of people i've seen
it was funny because right when i began
sensing this in myself
and i was talking about it with jessie
you know she's a twitter queen she's
immediately points me to like
five tweets that had already emphasized
the same sentiment
which is as things get ready to turn
back to normal
you start feeling a little anxiety about
life returning to normal now for some
people that might be like not just a
little anxiety i mean
some people it might be like a social
anxiety like i don't want to get around
people that's not it for me it's just
and i'm not much of a routine person but
there's something about the fact that
we've been able to conduct our business
kind of
uninterrupted right like so we're we're
we're one of the lucky privileged
that we we get to do our business in a
way that is
i mean it's changed a lot but yeah it's
unencumbered in a lot of ways our
business
has been altered drastically but we've
gotten so used to it
that it is the new normal and i mean
that's a whole other podcast to get into
but all that but being at home uh
not traveling uh a lot like we used to
do
i mean i haven't been going to the gym
and i kind of turned my garage into a
gym
you know i and i kind of am into this
sort of predictability
and routine and and sort of like the
simple life
i'm being home every surprise to hear
that from you because
that's not something i would expect or
that's not maybe
it surprises you that you have those
feelings that well
i'm ready to travel because for me but
i'm not ready for
the day-to-day life to turn back into
hectic always all over the scramble yeah
but you know for me my personality type
like totally gotten used to my world
being smaller and
more predictable and insulated and
it just feels i mean more narrow
but there's a good side to that too
because it
there's a sense of increased safety and
you know for me
safety control yeah control i understand
i mean it started with safety
and so you kind of have this ingrained
sense of like
you you have some people may struggle
with this innate feeling of
i've trained myself to believe that
safety is is
hunkered down so going out must mean the
opposite
even though being fully vaccinated and
the you know
the realities of a full vaccination and
the safety associated with that is just
something that like
the facts don't immediately translate
into
feelings is what we're that's a big
discussion that's happening
in our home um you know i was even
telling lincoln last night i was trying
to paint a picture for
you know once we're fully vaccinated
these are some things that we can start
doing and
he got this look on his face like he
hadn't even thought about it
you know it's like because you go you
live in this space where it's like
you don't even just don't even think
about what could be
or what you're missing out on type of
thing and then so it's like you
compartmentalize
and so me giving him just starting to
paint a picture for how things could
open up it was like he got this
this he just kind of stared for a while
and then he got this big grin on his
face it must be nice you mean you're
telling me that your kid hasn't
constantly berated you
for a full year about how all the stuff
he can't do
constantly arguing with you about that
no he's just gone that's the way it's
been at my house
yeah so you know it's kind of like when
you let a
you you know you got this dog in a
kennel maybe they've been in there for a
long time
maybe it's their safe cave space and
then you open the door
and you're like he's just gonna he's
just laying there
i think what you're saying bursting is
that your family
is much more susceptible to being in a
cult than mine which brings me to this
sense of a commune because like
as we've been talking about communes
i've had to really work to not use the
word cult
every single time there are there's a
reason there's a different thing but
there's some overlap that we can talk
about
but yeah this like um if
instead of returning back to the big
wide world
what if i just skipped over to
commune life where it's a you know a
defined
group of people with shared values that
are keeping things
simple and you have to imagine that most
people who are in communes
who were in communes before kovid and in
communes through kovid and after kovid
their lives have probably changed less
covid what they're like i mean yeah
we're in a commune
big whoop i mean
sustainability peaceful cooperation
no bills no
no boss no responsibilities think again
just my friend you know like just
food that everyone gets to eat
no competition seem wonderful it does
connecting with nature and with strange
people
who are misfits in normal society but
perfect fits in some of these communes
that we'll talk about um
i'm like let's go and i'm not
saying it like the kids use the phrase
as like just a form of
they say like a positive expletive
yeah no like you mean like it's a that's
a new slang or
what i mean it's a few years old but
everybody's like let's go
if they like something
you but this is like newer than just
like 10
like 50 years ago let's go like you
would say to like a team
whatever you're cheering for this is
like slang i've i've heard your own
children
say that i don't listen to what my kids
talk about you haven't heard like
i mean if you listen to the baby
every so often he's gonna interject
let's go
and he's not asking people to come with
him somewhere he's just like
yeah it's a celebratory i don't think
there's a phrase
but i think i don't think it's change
what i thought what you were saying is
that let's go has changed meaning since
like the 50s
and i don't think it has yes it has it
doesn't mean
let's gather together and head towards
the same destination i don't know i know
i'm just saying that like let's go like
like get pumped up
yeah it's not that's not what it means
now it doesn't mean
let's get pumped up okay what does it
mean though it means
i'm excited it just
means it feels like with some semantics
here
let's go let's get excited oh no let's
get pumped up and let's get excited
sort of feel like let's go is trying to
pump someone up like to conjure up
the energy to do something but
let's go is like it's just like
i love this i'm celebrating this i don't
need to conjure anything up i have an
overflow of emotion
okay that now translates into a hip-hop
track
interjection so you're not saying you
want to go to a communion you're saying
you're excited about the idea
no so you are using it i am using it in
the
in the in the traditional okay old out
of touch since then
you should understand i'm not confused
let you and i
head towards the world of communes and
decide which one we want to
physically go to and live okay are we
clear yeah
i'm clear now um but yeah but they want
they want
them to be called intentional
communities because people intend to go
there and they're not like held there
against their free will at least that's
what they
say communes have a bad rap which we'll
we'll get into
well a throwback to a conversation we
had um
with the uh when we're talking about
pythagoras
he is credited we're always talking
about pythagoras as uh creating the
first
intentional community in recorded
history at
home on the greek word
in 525 bce um
they tried to create an ideal society
gave up private property and meat
and apparently beans as well as we
discussed i would just
interject quickly here people were
getting i take issues
i take issue with this this is kind of
like
uh when a white guy in a boat like
discover something that you know brown
people who've been living there for
thousands of years have
already known about foreign
because um intentional community is
basically the
history of the human race like the idea
of private property is something that
the western world brought over here to
the native americans so like
the idea of intentional community i
think is actually the baseline
understanding of human community but it
wasn't until
agriculture and property on all that
stuff that we then had to
kind of undo that to then create what
we're calling an intentional community i
guess in 525 bc
yeah you know okay point taken within
the context of
western civilization okay yeah then
you've got to have
if if you if you have this shared belief
or approach to life that that means
you're going to give up your personal
belongings
which you have if you're giving it up in
order to
be a member of a community where you're
sharing everything basically post
property ownership
the the post the the idea of property
ownership yes
i mean the early christians they lived
communally uh
a few centuries later christian
monasteries became a major form of
international intel i said international
intentional community
uh so we could become monks
you know you know this is interesting
because i'm reading this book kind of
about early christian history
and uh it's actually kind of fascinating
just how you know whatever word you want
to use
uh communist socialist progressive
whatever you wanted to use that early
christians were at the time
i'm not talking about in the like sense
of like the way they saw government or
necessarily
but just the way that their community
was very much
communist in the strictest sense of the
word and it was
like it was the lower class it was
men and women and it was in
is so interesting that christianity got
hijacked
by the powers that be um and kind of
became what it has been for
you know over well over a thousand years
but in the early stages it was very it
was it was kind of a different thing it
was it was a lot more about
class and it was a lot more about kind
of rebelling against the powers that be
and then the powers that be were like oh
we can use this to our advantage and
kind of created
the hierarchy that we kind of see within
the you know the church
am i right in remembering that in paul's
letter to
one of the churches you know he kind of
talks about the mechanism of
um sharing everything
right and he kind of put some specifics
in that about
like and like kind of like the the heart
and the motivation behind like giving up
your possessions for
for the comments i'm sure he talks about
that i mean i think it's mostly in
uh acts you know luke wrote luke and axe
and so
that may be what i'm thinking about acts
you know basically the
the the the you know history of the
early church kind of talks about what
they did and kind of sold their
possessions and came together and lived
communally and
and uh we're kind of specifically
specifically reacting to what was
happening on a societal level
and that was one of the things that made
it attractive and also controversial at
the time because it was kind of
saying that the authority doesn't lie
with these dudes who say that they're in
charge
authority lies with god so
um but it quickly got taken and
you know distorted we could also in my
opinion
we could also go to israel and join a
kibbutz
i think is how you would say it so um i
mean those
those are around now they've been
they've been around and there's like
there's there's the religious and the
non-religious kind there's like
and there's a lot more of the
non-religious
kibbutz sorry i i apologize if i'm
saying that wrong well and i and i would
think that this
is something that especially with what
we're seeing with
uh what we've experienced in 2020 in
2021 thus far
um you know this deep wealth inequality
and um people just so many people
struggling i think the
idea of kind of stepping out of this
pursuit of the american dream
um and i know i'm you know
not talking about just americans but i'm
we're in america
uh it's got to be an attractive thing
like
you know you mean i can quit trying to
keep up with the joneses
and worry oh cliche the rat the joneses
the rat race going to the right college
and
getting the right job to pay off the
deep debt that i acquired in order to go
to college
the idea of saying hey can't we all just
get along
i believe that this has never been
a more attractive idea i mean in recent
history this has got to be
a super attractive idea right now so i
do think that
we probably should start with some
cautionary tales before you get too
excited
okay yeah i about being a part of a
commune all right or an intentional
community all right let's get into the
bad news
um or just you know we need to tread
lightly the one that you've all heard
about
the jonestown massacre where the saying
don't drink the kool-aid comes from
uh late 70s i did not know the details
of this
yeah so lots of lots of really good
documentaries
that you can watch about this um but
late 70s jim jones was a preacher
uh he was he began his commune for
social justice and equality he was
calling it the people's temple that
sounds good
for the people you know it's got like
the temple in it that seems fancy
but then he made the move he moved it
from san francisco
san francisco san francisco to guyana
uh first of all you just gotta okay okay
maybe a red flag here he's moving he's
moving further away from
prying eyes right i mean that's one way
to see it
and i think that's what was happening so
people started to because there's a lot
of american people who were involved
with this
and they were worried that they were
being held against their will and it
kind of became this
story so much so that a congressman leo
ryan
decides to visit to make sure that the
residents are okay
and this is the late 70s late 70s and uh
he shows up along with four others and
they are
shot to death when they get out of the
plane at the airstrip so another red
flag
yeah that's that's not a good start to
the diplomatic oversight
and then shortly thereafter i don't
really remember the timeline but jones
he forced
or strongly encouraged uh his followers
to drink a
cyanide laced flavor aid starting with
the children
poor kool-aid it wasn't even kool-aid it
was
flavor aid right you know but but now
you got this saying
don't drink the kool-aid matter of fact
i heard it on an episode of survivor you
hear it everywhere but of course i hear
everything on survivor because that's a
lot of songs
of media and that's gonna have to be in
any community i attend
don't drink the flavor aid just doesn't
sound quite cause like what's flavor aid
right uh so some people tried to flee
and they survived it
but those people did some people tried
to flee and they shot them
because they didn't drink the kool-aid
in over 900 people
including kids were killed yeah almost a
thousand people that is
that is gross so anyway i mean it's 900
people it may have sounded awesome it's
a lot of flavoring
but uh so that's one cautionary tale
gosh
now you and i have talked about the
source family before
we may have talked about it on this show
there was there was a netflix
documentary
like in the wake of um what was that
netflix documentary
that the duplex brothers were executive
producers uh
country back uh no
no country for commune people oh wild
wild country wild wild
country great feeling when you remember
something that you've forgotten
that that was so on the heels of that
i think we were looking for other stuff
to watch and we i watched this
documentary you watched it too
oh this is a great documentary as well
um
world war ii vet who became known as
father yad
great name uh yeah i don't think that
was his original name
father yad that's one thing i love about
comedy is that you can change your name
you can change everybody's name as it
turns out right he
created the first vegetarian restaurant
in l.a
had many young wives and had many
younger children with those young lives
that's how children work they recorded
music and
sold the albums uh very hippy-dippy like
seemed like a great 70s situation um but
his caution you know you got to watch
who you're following because this is
when this stuff is you know
this is when you get in occult territory
in both of these situations
but the thing that i didn't realize
until i went back and read about this
was how father yacht died
they had moved they saw their restaurant
and moved to hawaii
in 1974 and then on august 25th 1975
according to wikipedia despite having no
previous hang gliding experience
father yad decided that he would indeed
go
hang gliding presumably solo
yad used a hang glider to leap off a
1300
foot that's 400 meters right cliff
on the eastern shore of oahu um
spoiler alert he died i already said
that he crash-landed on the beach
get this he's suffering no external
injuries
he just looked like rick rubin correct
lying on a beach
you know it's just like white dude with
a really long white beard
like rick looks like these days just
laying on the beach suffering no
external injuries
but he was unable to move and he died
nine hours later no that's a horrible
death
if that's what getting into a commune
means i'm out
i mean there's a guy at the end of my
street who has a hang glider that's what
and i look at that
thing and it freaking it makes my balls
hurt
i don't understand that yeah you never
stood on the edge of a cliff you say
this balls hurt
you say this every single time it's the
defense mechanism for not falling off a
cliff or yachting your way down on a
hang glider
well i i i didn't my yards tell me i
didn't don't hang glasses
i didn't tell you this uh so you know a
couple weeks ago we talked about the
eject button
that you press in order to lots of
conversation
and uh in our conversation that you
weren't able to join last night with our
college friends
uh it was confirmed that neither of them
knew about the buttons
what yeah they didn't have they haven't
pressed the button
so apparently something i thought was
very common
we educated a lot of people is what i
learned yeah
so anyway especially taking it to the
next level okay so yeah uh
in i don't know i know how it ended for
father yad and first of all
i do remain open to the fact that i
might be father yad reincarnated just
because of the time of his death and the
time of my birth and
this is the way we are affinity for hang
gliding um i like the idea of hang
gliding never done it
but it doesn't make my balls hurt when i
think about it but let's get let's get
into some
current ones and make a decision but
first
let's promote some merch uh
good-looking speaking of cults and
communes i mean this is
one of the more occulty illuminati
issues
let's make sure they can see i mean
basically you know this is supposed to
be a magic eight ball but it's that
triangle which is the s
you know which is definitely
illuminati-ish mythical outlook
what does it say good mythical morning
outlook mythical
yes outlook mythical it just says
mythical mythical
outlook mythical oh okay mythical
mythical outlook mythical and if you
shake
it changes yeah it changes in your brain
we should we
should have made the shirt where when
you shake the friction with your
booby area or sternum makes that
triangle
make something else appear do you think
we could have put a little pocket in
there that held
liquid and a little dice why don't we
just make it a hole
die you can just see your chest hair
through it well why don't we sell a
t-shirt
with two holes over the nipples not
everybody's nipples are in the same
place i've thought about this many times
cut them yourself but we sell the
scissors
okay all right mythical.com might be
onto something rep your boys
okay tell us about a current cult
that we might want to join i wanted to
start close okay
so interview in america sorry john
commune i keep saying cole i'm sorry
it's hard
in this community intentional community
um
so let's go to central tennessee near
the town of summertown tennessee
this place is called the farm uh there's
200 residents i like everything about
this over um
it started in the 70s by this hippie guy
last name
gaskin he still lives there but
but i mean in that this commune
which is like you know it's out in rural
tennessee you got a whole bunch of buses
that people are living in um
buses in the 80s it got up to like 1200
people
in the 80s and then they kind of they
had to change things in order to
um they had a lot of debt
and then they had they had to figure out
how to okay you can't you got to start
supporting yourself and of course a lot
of people
left when they're like hey it's a
commune but you support yourself
yeah that doesn't work but they kind of
revamped everything
and they they developed their own little
cottage industries
and um now they're at 200 people
and you can go visit for like a long
weekend and decide if you want to stay
there
it seems like a lot of journalists go
there in order to write a little piece
to
to titillate the minds of people like us
but
i mean i'll just point out some of the
pros with this place it's it's
it's it's in america it's
accessible to us uh i've been to
tennessee
if you need to get to nashville you know
in an hour and a half or so you can do
that is it close to gatlinburg because
that's what i'm concerned about
um they have an extremely successful
midwifery
you know the the why who help you have
birth yes the wife of the founder
um i i think her name's like ida may or
something she's more famous than him
because the book she wrote about
uh midwifery in fact the farm
was the setting for the rebirth
of midwifery for the united states and
the creation of the modern home birth
method wow and movement i love watching
those on youtube so you can live in a
bus
and then have a baby in the bus so is
this just people who are members of the
commune who are having babies or is it
like
if you want to have a baby you can go i
don't know but i think because she's so
famous maybe people will go to her for
i mean if you really want to like have a
famous midwife she's the one
she's the one she's still around yeah
you got to be uh
vegan but that's that's kind of an
assumption
that's right seems right uh and there's
a lot of
you know with the whole changeover and
everything there are still some
residents that were there from the
beginning in the 70s and went through
the whole changeover and
they saw it in all its glory and like i
said even the founder and his wife are
still
there but there's a lot of infighting
between those boomers
and newer residents who are coming in
trying to do it trying to do it
differently yeah i
which that kind of reminds me you
you have this idea of you got this group
of like-minded people that you're living
off the land and supporting each other
and
every you know everybody helps raise the
kids and
you share everything but
and and this is not really that much
that much of a legitimate comparison but
it's kind of
all that i have to go on like in all the
like bible study groups
that i was involved in that you were
involved in like growing up especially
like the young married groups like once
we graduated from college
for me it was like it was no way like a
commune except that like
you get together with these people and
you start making these connections with
a small group of people
and it gets really exciting and
over the course of my my life in that
world there were a few
phases or iterations of a small group
getting together like a bible study or
like a family group or whatever you
might call it
and you'd be like this is a magical
connection we all really like each other
it's like now we have this like dynamic
friend group
and it never it never lasts more than
like
two years because it you know what it
comprises
of people you know people getting
like getting in each other's business is
a tough thing to maintain
and even when it just comes hey let's
get together once a week and encourage
each other and help each other and
in this case study the bible it was like
we were all very well intentioned and it
wasn't that
there wasn't it wasn't dogmatic in
really any way but still
the personalities and like the slight
different pulls of agenda
i want it to be like this well i want to
do this and this is the vision i have
and my my needs aren't being met my
expectations aren't being met it's so
any group of people it's not just a
church thing or a commune thing it's so
hard
well and i think keep it going there's a
there's an additional factor that may
actually be
the sort of foundational problem even
beyond the personalities hang gliders
not hang gliders the fact that you don't
have to be in that group
in the modern world every community that
you're a part of
that's why they call it intentional
community it's not
we have no choice but to be this
community that's called a prison
right or a cult well no but if you go
back okay first of all like if you go
way
back in the distant past where there was
no choice but to be a part of your
community
and even in some places still in the
world where it's just like i can't i
don't make the choice about where i go
to church there's one church in town
yeah i don't make the choice about what
religion i'm gonna be there's one
option in this particular place and
when when your community is constituted
in that way
uh there's just so few choices
that those personalities are something
you deal with but in modern
in the modern world and modern america
in this in the south world and this is
true all of america but
like if you think about this bible study
group if i don't
like the voice of the person leading the
bible study i'm going to do another
bible study
in the same church or i can go to
another in the same house
it's like well there's a there if you
want to know just an all women's one
that one's happening downstairs
we've got we're overwhelmed with options
and so i mean you literally can go to
a first baptist church or a second
baptist church or even since some towns
i've seen the freaking third baptist
church
in the same town and that's just the
baptists
and that's just the christians so and
let's not
let's not just pick on church i mean i'm
saying this is
everybody this is all any group of
people yeah like if you want to talk
about
you know i don't i mean our our friend
group
post church you know i mean
that there was it was like there was a
dynamic experience for like a little
over a year
and then things just you know people
went their separate ways
well a lot of people have said uh even
after us telling our stories and you
know
because we exhibit an openness towards
spirituality in general and we're not
trying to be like naturalists atheists
and
and um just basically rule out all
mystical things people are like
you know it sounds like you you guys
would really enjoy a unitarian
universalist church
now i'm not saying i i wouldn't and i'm
not saying that i would never
try it but the idea that somehow
because that particular group of people
is committed to a more open
or progressive mindset that then there
would no longer be the problems of
people working together and ego
that's just not true no matter how
wonderful the foundational principles
of your community like you said it's
still going to be people
and it's still going to be people in the
context of this society where i can be
like
i don't have to be at this place i can
just go to the other place and if that's
if as long as those options exist
long-term peaceful community of any kind
is going to be very difficult
even if you don't to get back to
communes you don't have like a str
like a strong centralized leader
like a dictator that kind of makes it
more cultish i was reading about another
one in virginia that like
you know they they all shared the duties
of raising the children in this
particular commune
and there was a couple that wanted to
have another child but
there was a protocol that you had to go
and get permission
because we all got to take care of this
to have a child so it's like it's even
coming from like a logistic place that
makes sense but you find yourself having
to get permission to have a
child well um but and you know which is
something that
completely rubs up against the rugged
individualism
of our modern society and especially
america the idea that i would have to
get
that i wouldn't own this piece of
property and the fact that i would have
to ask permission to have a kid
it seems almost offensive to to most of
us
but i do think the idea that hey i'm a
member of this collective
and every decision that i make is going
to impact every other member of the
collective
it kind of makes sense it sort of
follows but it violates our sense of
individualism
i mean we went to different churches um
as newlyweds uh and as we graduated from
college
like we didn't actually you know we
never went to the same we grew up in the
same church but we didn't go to the same
church
right um after college right until the
point where we no longer went to church
we didn't think people could handle us
going to the same church
um i mean it was good to have some
autonomy but
i mean so in in that phase of life did
you have a similar experience to me that
like
you had this supercharged small group
that you thought was gonna be
like connected forever did you did you
experience the magic
before the disappointment uh i i
wouldn't say it was
as uh marked of a magic and a
disappointment as it seems like you're
talking about but i completely
understand
i mean we had a we had a pretty
consistent
group it was sort of a core group of
people uh
probably for five six years or so
um but again it was the kind of thing
that we came together as a bible study
and it was a great time
but there wasn't a whole lot of
interaction outside of that group and
then sunday
because everybody had other friends and
everybody had their lives and their jobs
again you did there was nothing
that was forcing your involvement with
uh with the other family and so it
wasn't as
it just wasn't a stark but i but i but
yeah i completely get what you're saying
i'm passing on the farm because i'm not
going to have any more kids
and uh i love the idea of living in a
van
but not a bus the reason i'm passing on
the farm is because
uh it just doesn't seem cool enough to
me but i'm about to give you something
that i think is getting into because
if i'm going to do a commune i want to
do
i want it to be weird let's go
um how about auroville
in indiana or india i thought
i thought i said indiana india man big
difference yeah yeah it's not in the end
i was just
i was throwing this cardboard in india
you got to travel to this one it better
be good
now you can go to the oroville.org
website which is got a lot of content
okay this is a multicultural city
started in the late 60s they believe
in human unity and transformation of
consciousness over 3 000 residents from
58 nations residents are expected to
build their own house
and make donations to the community but
beyond this all necessities including
public school utilities
health care are covered by the community
um
which is technically partially funded by
the indian government but that let's not
complicate things
now let me just say i have created what
i am calling the cool [ __ ] factor
okay okay yeah to judge these these
communes
all right all right and that's really
what it's all about
how cool is your [ __ ] auroville has a
lot of cool [ __ ] and let me just
tell you a few things the first thing i
see these pictures now
they started the community in this area
in in
uh not indiana india and they decided
that the
center of the entire thing would be this
i think it's banyan tree i think it's
how you say that but those are those
sort of
iconic uh you've seen these trees on
like postcards if you haven't seen them
in person
the buddha was enlightened under it
under one and so
there's this banyan tree that is in the
middle of
this kind of stark landscape and they
decided that this was the center of the
community i just
like that kind of thing you know me and
you with our like
declaring a tree special yeah we do we
do this
and but that's they didn't just say
here's a tree no
then yeah they constructed this thing
called
the matrimander and this is
it looks like a
golden epcot synthetic right like or it
looks like well not it looks like
shiny epcot sphere the sphere at epcot
and this thing has took forever to build
but ins first of all you can visit this
thing like anybody can visit this thing
but inside oh wow this
golden ball structure
there is the largest optically perfect
glass globe in the world and on the
website they go through
how they had this thing manufactured so
so like a big paperweight it well but
it's optically
perfect optical meaning it looks perfect
but it's probably not
it's not microscopically perfect well i
think it says perfect
there's no other glass globe of this
size that is this perfect
and what did they do with it i mean i'm
sure they get like energy from it or
something
i don't know they meditate on it and you
sit on it and try to hatch i don't think
you said on it
i think that would probably be like a
violation yeah that's probably rule
number two
i don't even know if you can touch it or
lick it that's real but you can look at
it
yeah i'm sure we're gonna get facts
wrong about this sorry those of you who
are like from
welcome first of all those of you from
auroville who are watching welcome to
the show
thanks we think you've got some cool
[ __ ] what's going on podcast called ear
biscuits
are we going we're coming for you do you
want to broadcast
it like that you could broadcast this
inside the
uh the the i know i'm saying it wrong
metromander put this on repeat like this
part of the podcast just
did you you know what feel free we are
officially giving you permission
to take this our description of your
place and put it
in a little video vignette on your
website okay and like a video brochure
if you will
anyway you got a lot of cool [ __ ] and
there's like
i like that big focal point the epcot
focal point that
you want yes exactly i want to see
something that like oh
that aliens may have been involved right
yeah they don't just have that they have
a giant amphitheater
and in the middle of the amphitheater is
just this marble urn
just a marble urn i see a picture where
they're like
it's a huge fire yeah i mean the
website's got some very intoxicating
images
so anyway i know there's more cool [ __ ]
that's just what we're going to talk
about
now uh the pros of this one you got your
healthcare
your school taken care of you can stay
for a trial period
okay how long is that uh i don't know
as long as it needs to be large group
diverse group
very high cool [ __ ] factor it was
started by a woman
they called the mother and i want to i i
want to take a second to camp out here
because you know i'm generalizing but
you know
does everyone camp out there when a dude
starts
a cult 99.7
percent of the time it's because he
wants to get with a bunch of women he
wants to get his yacht on
yeah but a woman or get his yards off
but
in my experience women are not just
interested in ripping families apart and
having sex with everybody
as much as men tend to be wow right so
i think that there could be this could
be a purer motivation here i think
they call her the mother and i think the
fact that she started now she's dead
but i think she according to them she
passed on into a different form and
still
is involved in some way maybe she's in
the ball
maybe she's in the urn which would make
more sense no comment
again if you want to take this part out
of the the little
video brochure on the website if i'm
getting all the details about the mother
wrong
i'm sorry you can do that yeah i'm just
saying i love the fact that a female
started your
your your your commune okay uh cons
you got to relocate to india you got to
build your own house
you know i don't like the i don't even
like to change the light bulbs anymore i
mean i just was going to be honest i did
a bunch of like manual stuff like
in my 20s like you know
i was like a mr fix it man like working
on rental properties and stuff and
i i i just i think communities don't
like it
you bring up a good point i think
communes are really for that like young
and vivacious type that wants to go grab
grab life by the yards there's a lot of
things i want to do
and then if you're old it's because
you've like you've you've been there for
a while you know i like the idea of
maybe gardening a little bit maybe a
little bit of woodwork
just for like an artistic standpoint but
not building a house
that's a lot yeah that's a lot and also
and i don't know if this is necessarily
a con but
you know the idea is to lose your your
sense of personal possessions
and your ego which i actually think that
that's a positive i wouldn't put that in
a con
uh it sounded like you did though well
uh i think you put this in a con
actually yeah
uh so maybe i love my ego maybe that's
just
pretty great i the more i would love to
lose
if i lost my ego completely yeah that'd
be great then i would lose any desire
for personal possessions
so i wouldn't care so that's a positive
to me if they
if i go and i i don't i guess if i if i
sit on or touch
the the glass orb maybe my ego gets
taken
and stored inside the optically perfect
orb and then maybe if i want it
and i want to leave and i gotta go to
america i need my ego i touch it and get
it back
is that how it works you can take this
out of the take this off the website if
that's not true i don't think that
one just rolls into a commune and then
explains how
all of their very meaningful things work
hey got news for you guys i'm going to
be sitting on this orb
and i'll you know i'll post the times
when i'm not on it if you want to bring
in tourists to look at it yeah right
otherwise you're just going to be
looking at me no
i was just saying that like kind of
nesting on this thing you know i'm going
to spend a lot of time i'm going to
deposit my ego into it and then i'm
going to walk out
okay and then if i need my ego for some
sort of like competition
sporting event so i'm going gonna go
play golf i need my ego so you're losing
your ego
yeah into this sphere but you're
basically doing that to assert that you
think everyone would want to look at
your ego
which kind of that's not like losing
your ego that is how you're interpreting
it i'm not you can't see anything in the
orb
it's not my ego is not the only ego
that's in the orb i'm assuming
everyone's ego is in the org orb
but it isn't org because this
auroville.org is the website
but what i'm telling you rhett is that
you're you're misinterpreting everything
that i'm saying which is why you don't
know no one's ego is in the orbs so if
you wouldn't make a good culture if you
put your ego in the orb it's going to be
the only one in there
period you just can't tell people that
oh you know everyone's eating no i'm
making some assumptions here and i might
be wrong i'm just saying
you are there are egos deposited in the
orb or the urn
or the tree then i'm part of that i'll
do that
let's go to scotland i i thought you'd
be into this yeah i used
i was scott scott scotland's [ __ ] one
time the fine horn
eco village now don't get your hopes up
there is no hidden horn
no because they found it that's not what
this is about
okay you know it reminds me of like
christie went to meredith college
all women's school where they it was
like they did all these summer camp
exercises like
by class by like freshman class junior c
and i think when you were a junior you
were supposed to
find the crook yeah that was hidden
by the seniors and it was
the crook i think i don't even know what
it was i think it's just
i i've never seen it and i never asked
christy what it was i just have this
i like a crook at like a picture of the
shot top of a
the bent top of a cane or like a
shepherd's staff
i don't know why but that's what i
always thought a crook was and i'm just
now realizing i've never seen it or
really asked christy what it was you'd
probably look it up on the internet but
it was kind of this game to find the
crook
kind of like finding a hidden immunity
idol and survivor right
boy i i don't i actually don't want to
be the guy that keeps talking about
survivor well you were too late
we found that horn
but finding the crook is not like
find horn eco village this thing started
in the 60s but it didn't take its
current
form until 1982 when residents made an
effort to
show that an environmentally unobtrusive
community could flourish both socially
and economically and obviously
um spiritually
no physical like naturally
okay uh it's been noted as having the
smallest environmental footprint of
any town in the modern world whoa okay
all right yeah
their building codes encourage like
using found materials
they use wind turbines or turbines
however
whatever your you know your jollies are
and they got a water treatment apparatus
called the living machine
okay now okay i like that that's weird
which makes use of algae
snails and plant life to purify the
community's drinking water
oh that's awesome um so this place is
you know it's like if you look on the
website it kind it's got this scottish
countryside farm vibe but there's
there's actually a lot of buildings and
and a good amount of streets but how
many people do you know
uh i don't know everybody bikes
everywhere no one counts how many people
there are okay
so don't worry about it got it got it um
but yeah i definitely want to drink of
this
living machine i'm into this yeah you
you can you have to build a house here
too oh really
and you but yeah i mean there's more
restrictions you got to build it out of
found material
you just take like people leave or die
can i just take that guy's house
uh like maybe like can i get on a
waiting list and be like ego is gonna
live here
with you until you decide to move out i
don't move in i want a waiting list
and i just want to be like hey i i don't
really want to build my house but it's
when
walter dies he's tall he's probably got
furniture that fits me and he's tall so
he won't live long
put me on the waiting list for walters
some houses are made from
old wine barrels that's kind of cool
there's a there's
that's a cool [ __ ] situation you could
maybe make an instagram
with that is that allowed um i don't
know
do any of these places have an instagram
no they just have a website they're they
they're all kind of behind you know they
don't really seem to care about social
media well instagram is all about ego
anyway so
that's not a good that's not a good
thing i think you can have your phone
out in public
and then you it's it's it's hard to like
get reception in some of these places
that's good this one's a this is
basically a demonstration farm
people come and they visit they're like
wow look at how eco-friendly this place
is
and self-sustaining it reminds me of
the demonstration farm on the edge of
bowie's creek
that i never knew what was what was
going on there it's like the one near my
house before you yeah
when i would ride my bike from my house
to yours i would have to go buy the
demonstration farm and it was a camel
university thing right
and they had they had sheep everywhere
and i do remember that we went
we took a trip there in like younger
grades
well the funny thing is we took a field
trip there
and because it was next to my house and
i was a little boy who got into
everything
i was like i've been up in this
demonstration farm a lot a lot
already yeah you took me there no i
would go and i would jump the fence and
i would run around with the goats and
the sheep and pet them and i would get
in
i would get into everything at the
demonstration farm without permission
and then occasionally would people show
up and would you demonstrate anything
uh i would be like this is how a little
i'm gonna demonstrate how a little boy
runs from the farmer and once he shows
up
i i remember that we would both
kind of scurry around and and um you
know trespass there was a there was a
male goat
that would ram you he was yeah he was
aggressive it's very aggressive and i
thought it was the coolest thing
but the daughter of the family that
lived on the farm before it became the
farm
that was that was uh that was jennifer
pearson
i didn't think we said last names
anymore okay jennifer
wonder what happened to jennifer pearson
a man i had a crush on her
you did you you really liked her i had a
crush on her man
in kindergarten i spent the night at her
house one time
because every time i say that i had a
crush on her you
then you this is this is what you say uh
you gloat
no no no you spent the night with her no
what with her brother she had a younger
brother and you know me i would invite
myself to
anybody he was so much younger yeah yeah
i i
he was three years younger i think
that's a lot when you're in
grade school i would do three years or
three years three years younger or three
there was a six year range that i felt
it was acceptable to spend the night at
somebody's house
because i was very interested in other
people's homes you're like 11 years old
and like you're spending the night with
an eight-year-old that's just weird
i i readily admit that it's weird
but it wasn't about him it was about the
goat it was about he lived on a farm he
had a sister my age
uh and i mean he and he accepted my
invitation for myself
it was a it was a white house one story
i never went inside of it i just thought
a lot about what it might be inside
there i can tell you i mean it's there
wasn't it wasn't a lot of cool [ __ ] in
there
oh really yeah i mean maybe that's true
of the eco village
i mean again i basically the only thing
i'm touting is
scotland is fun you can ride your bike
everywhere it's dangerous though but you
also have to ride your bike everyone
broke her ankle there living machine
water
taste test i like that i watch i like
that idea it was criticized a few years
back for advertising
alternative healing is not recommended
by science
they have since rebranded but isn't that
just part of being
in one of these communities of course i
mean the whole right new age deal i mean
of course they're
healing in ways that don't aren't
scientific so i i like
that's what it's about right they're
teaching good things and they're like
they're not i don't think they're
religious or even philosophical
it's more just about like eco-friendly
self-sustaining
well that's attractive but it's also
hard to get people to fully commit
right it's a bit you need them to swear
off their own family
and and swear allegiance to something
above themselves
well in order to be an effective
communist i think so
scotland doesn't do it i think um you
know
gold epcot right now
yeah but i've got one that's going to
maybe shake things up the federation
i gave you all the good ones of dom and
her this is a good one
in italy first of all always wanted to
go to italy
i mean just right off the bat the
federation of dominguer
often simply called dominehr
is a commune eco village that's also an
eagle village and spiritual community
situated in the piedmont region of
northern italy about
50 kilometers that's about 31 miles
north of the city of turin
shroud of turin anybody oh yeah you can
swing by the shroud and then go down
there and visit i know they make tours
because i
i watched one on youtube yeah oh yeah
there's okay
this thing was founded in 1975 by a dude
alberto
so there's a question both dil there
just because the dude founded it
but he founded it with 24 followers uh
and by the year 2000
it had grown to 800 i don't know exactly
what it is now
but they hold kind of a mix of new age
and neopagan beliefs which i think is
that feels right to me we're in a sweet
spot now
neo-pagan now hold on
to your yards because
the cool [ __ ] thank you for using that
the cool [ __ ] factor
at this place is off the charts
but under the ground the temples of
humankind
yes we're talking hand dug 100 feet
deep tunnels and chambers
that have all this stuff including
i love hand dug stuff but that's a
hundred feet too i mean that's crazy
i love underground stuff i i haven't
done a whole lot of it but the idea of
being
in caves and underground especially
thing that's been dug into the ground
big fan i'm not a fan of it as long as
you can
walk around in a pretty much upright
position once
you're starting to belly crawl
underground no no no we're not talking
speed lunk in here i do i've done that
before
we're not talking speed locking we're
talking it's the hall of spheres
containing translucent orbs containing
water imbued with spiritual energy
intended for use in meditation so we
don't we're not just talking about one
perfect we're talking about
multiple spear spheres with water in
them
that's been imbued the hall of earth
which has a dreamlike murals
of landscapes and extinct animals
calling attention to human
responsibility to the planet's
preservation yeah every uh
like there's like paintings of these
animals all over the wall and it's kind
of like
walking through a human-sized ant farm
yeah like it's like you go through this
there's a door and then
it's it's you can tell that things were
built on and added as they went
yeah there wasn't some grand scheme to
this thing it was more like
big room let's paint it put orbs in here
let's make a tunnel this way
and so it's you know it's very ant like
and i'm not done
hall of mirrors an area for meditation
surrounded on all sides
by mirrors i would expect no less the ps
there is this dance
i don't know exactly where it's at but i
can confirm that on the website
i saw a woman with a gong and
if you're if you've got a commune and
there is not a gong
you have done it wrong just remember
that okay
commune with no gong you've done it
wrong
now so and i and i've only scratched the
surface so to speak i mean you do have
to go 100 feet deep but
this is a beautiful area and their
website i mean it's
crazy their website is crazy what is the
website i guess i just went to uh
this is the i get a lot of this from the
wiki entry but they've got a good
website too with a lot of information
and you can visit you can commemorate
your dot org
okay you should click on this should be
orb
sustainability is the present and the
future the thing that i notice
is that they they've got like these
different
what are they called they're like
symbols different these symbols
represent
there was a lot of organization in terms
of like where you could
fit in in this community and like your
level of commitment
it's it's a very it's a grand system but
they're not trying to not be
culty which is what's something i
appreciate let's just go ahead and admit
that's what we're doing here guys
we are a cult right it's like this is
not hey
an intentional community eco village no
it's a freaking cult let's be honest
about it
let's embrace it that's what that's why
we're doing this so i like that about it
and also i like the fact that they have
four levels of participation a b c and d
now well they call them classes that's
what i'm talking about just like this
whole system you can
assimilate so one class is you got to
live there full time
that's class a class b you got to be
there three times a week like three days
a week and then class c and
contribute money class c and d you can
live anywhere
but you know this depends on like what
kind of like course you're in there's a
lot of meditation there's a school of
meditation
there's this thing called the game of
life what i don't even understand it but
i'm in and let me say this like an
underground board game that you could
die
yeah the other thing is from 1983
onwards members have assumed animal
names and not just animal names
you get an animal first name and a plant
last name so the founder
is about is called falcon dandelion
and i've already picked my name i'll
give you some time to think about yours
okay but well falcon dandelion i'm going
and just so y'all know look out for
giraffe kudzu giraffe kudzu you got a
long neck and you grow fast
that's right giraffe kudzu in the house
where is he at is he in the hall of
mirrors he's tall but it's not really
the no
he's at the gong giraffe's my favorite
animal and they're very tall that's
simple kudzu
is a southern invasive with that
beardier
it's like you don't even have a neck
it's not about the neck it's about the
overall height don't criticize my
freaking name come up with your own
giraffe kudzu will be with will be gone
i'm coming
and i want to be the gong operator um
that's the only stipulation
uh multiple gongs in fact i want a haul
of gongs i'm not necessarily gonna dig
it
but i will supervise the digging
and i will supervise the purchasing of
the gongs and i will
attempt to construct a long stick that i
will use to strike the gongs
i think you'll attempt to do that you
find a stick
i will be called um
trichognosis rosebud is trichonosis an
animal no that is a
disease that you get from raw pork right
but it is an animal i mean it's worms i
guess
i think it's the disease you get from
the worm trichinosis worm
rosebud rosebud okay so it's like i i'm
i'm entering into this place and i'm wrb
i'm basically can i just go you twerk
yeah yeah yeah i like that
just call me twerp but i want you to
know that could you fetch a stick for me
i'm not trying to i'm not a dog i'm a
man
i'm a man who's you know what i'm i'm
bringing i'm coming to you warts and all
right gnosis okay you know i'm not i'm
not
trying to be something nice or something
i'm not
well what are you gonna do though i'm
gonna you know what i'm gonna do i've
already
decided that um i'll i'll probably dig
holes
i mean you'll be a digger i'm gonna be a
dick i like i mean
as a kid man i would love to dig a good
you're also a good cleaner
you love cleaning things could you clean
the kongs well once you dig a hole
it creates lots of debris to clean up i
don't think you have to clean a gong
very often i'm not cleaning your gongs
no
that's an emphatic no i think you polish
a gong you like polishing things
uh i've i've never you know i'm gonna
answer this truth
truthfully and thoughtfully you've never
polished it i don't i can't recall
polishing
anything it's the world of polishing i
mean waiting for a twerp
to show up when i first got that that
pickup truck when i was 16
you know i would wax it is waxing a form
of polish yes
i think waxing is a sub-genre of
polishing and trigonosis is an animal
yeah okay you can have it your way man
i'm a hole digger man i i guess if i'm a
hole digger i should be
an animal that digs hulls okay uh i i'm
on board
i just can't think of one a lot of pros
here a dog
a lot of pros here the name names
one of them gongs uh super high high
uh cool [ __ ] factor you don't have to
live there full time i think you can
come in at level c
or d and kind of feel things out calling
everybody an animal
is some cool [ __ ] oh yeah now
there are some cons um
with all the pros that come from being
very cult-like
uh there are also some cons let's be
honest
uh basically the guru makes all your
decisions for you
uh there is some estrangement from
family oh there's some typical cult
situation things that are happening here
if you're not comfortable with that
if you if you if you don't like the idea
of being brainwashed and manipulated
which i understand some people don't
then this might not be for you
none of that came up in the tours that i
saw like
like fun for louie remember him uh-huh
he was there with uh shoot what is that
gal's name who was in our crate she was
in our crayon
colors music video
remember way back in the day she was she
was a vlogger at the time and
i can't remember her name but she uh
nadine
i think that's her name like they were
there together like many years ago and
like posted
youtube videos just visiting just
visiting and like
just like post vlogging about i'm just
saying they went through they went
through the chambers you can experience
the chambers and probably the gong
just by visiting do you think that the
fact that i said that but they didn't
mention any of this cult like well i do
i'm just i'm kind of
first of all just for legal reasons
might i say that everything i'm saying
here is for entertainment purposes
seems like that should go at the top um
i'm just saying that there's been
they've been accused let's just say
allegedly uh there are some there are
some cult-like
uh things happening here and some
control
issues that are happening but like i
said
i don't think you can do this properly
without that
you know and i'm not trying to listen
people cults you know people they get a
bad rap
people have suffered people have
suffered incredible
horrors and traumas from cult so i'm not
i'm not pro i'm not
saying pro i'm pro cult i'm just saying
if you're gonna do a community that's
got a bunch of cool [ __ ]
there's gonna be some mind control and
some manipulation it's just kind of part
of the package
you know what i'm saying um so
just keep all that in mind you also if
you're going to live there full time
you're going to be in a house with 10 to
20 people
uh oh see this isn't going to be an
adjustment it's going to be adjustment i
mean for you
you know i i think would be an
adjustment from me giraffe kudzu
is going to have a tough time with that
but i don't know i think i could adjust
i think i could adapt
i'm just going to go back to auraville
and into india
or maybe indiana maybe there's like a
miniature version
that quickly you went back i mean i
don't know that oroville doesn't have
some of the same what are you afraid of
at the
uh you scared me off with the i mean not
being able to make any decisions
you know you can make decisions but you
got to make decisions that are approved
right that's probably the same auroville
i'll take
one gold orb and one really smooth orb
within it
instead of all those chambers even
though i like to dig holes
okay i think that's where i'm landing i
think i'm going to italy
going underground assuming that i can
get these things that i've requested and
assuming that the people are going to
still be okay with the fact that i
said the stuff about mind control here's
what i'm saying
i understand that it's part of the deal
and i'm and i'm giraffe kudzu is showing
up
he's going to be on the gongs he's
willing to let his mind get controlled
so i'm just saying i'm i'm going to i'm
going to submit when i get there to my
guru
okay okay so you can just call me don't
sue me
tricky if you call me tricky i might
join you
that's better than tricky sounds like a
carny that got fired
short for trigonosis man i understand
what it comes from but
well i got the wreck this week uh i'm
gonna
so switching gears a little bit for a
record baby wreck baby one two
three four i i'm gonna recommend a video
so a video yeah i just want you to watch
a video
and this is this is more for you but if
like
you know i i think i think most
everybody listening
um would get a kick out of this
if you google well if you search on
youtube
i've only eaten mac and cheese for the
past 17 years here's why
a video will show up called i've only
eaten mac and cheese for the past 17
years and here's why
it's on the vice youtube channel i know
what you're recommending it's almost got
10 million views yeah i saw this thanks
to a reddit post on the good mythical
morning thread
um and it's
it's a profile piece of you guessed it a
guy who has
only eaten mac and cheese for the past
17 years
and this video tells you why
um he has as we discussed on good
mythical morning
we did a whole episode about people
eating only one thing
and it you know it did really well this
is like for many many years ago i barely
remember even doing the episode
um but i did remember a little bit and i
knew from the reddit thread that
like there's a connection well halfway
through this vice piece as it's doing
this profile i think it's a 18 minute
video
it's about five minutes in that's when
he gets into his story of
after having eaten mac and cheese for
a lot of his life he's he talks about
how he's watching this internet show
called good mythical morning
and they show a clip of us
talking about people eating one thing
like we talk about how
it's there's a name for that it's a
condition it's a mental
condition and he did not know
that he had a mental condition until he
watched good mythical mourning
and we told him the thing that ma and
then he goes on
is like and talks about like his
treatment it's a it's a pretty cool
video to watch and that that's the only
time we mentioned but it blew my mind
and it actually you know
if you would have reminded me that we
made that episode of gmm
and then that someone who has that
condition would have watched it
and you know i would have cringed a
little bit but i hope i didn't hurt we
didn't hurt that guy's feelings
oh i think we helped him but we clearly
helped this guy
like we were the catalyst to get him on
a path of
um coming to grips with what he's
dealing with in treatment
like there's literally it's a little
strange because it's
it's it goes to a therapist session and
it's filmed
it you know it's right they film the
thing so it's
there's a strange vibe in that exchange
but
maybe it was just because of the you
know the fact that it was a therapy
session being filmed but
um overall i was just i was relieved to
find out that we
only helped the guy and that so
even though we might have gotten a kick
out of people eating only one thing it's
more of a fascination
than like making fun of it's what
i think we struck a good balance one so
that we actually could help this guy so
changing the world one person at a time
man it's just it was it was surreal to
watch that a couple weeks ago so
and it's been out for it's been out for
a while uh this video came out a year
ago and then our video
was like years before that right yeah
yeah yeah
so check it out did you share the name
of it i've eaten only mac and cheese for
the past 17 years
comma here's why okay so basically it's
the title is the
yeah the thing that i've said multiple
times right vice
youtube channel well thanks for
listening to us
uh those of you who are in any of these
intentional communities
uh who joined us for this episode thank
you for joining us
let us know we may be joining you soon
about your experience
uh if you visited a commune or one of
these places hashtag your business and
if we got something wrong
as i'm sure we did in the least you know
how we pronounce some of these things
but some of the assumptions that
i made about your establishments let us
know hashtag your biscuits join the
conversation
set us straight we'll talk i do next
week
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left
and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best